i received an email
from a popular pub restaurant in my
constituency just
giving me these frankly terrifying
figures about what they were going to be
asked to pay for their energy so
i wanted to focus on the fact that
businesses are finding it tough as well
as households yeah i remember speaking
to a pub owner actually on sunday and
just been completely shocked actually
frankly by the kind of increases that
they were going to be seeing and what
did you make of the prime minister's
response well i mean i i welcome the
very clear response that
the package that will be announced
tomorrow will include
help for businesses as well as
households i mean obviously we don't
know what that is yet but it was really
reassuring because of course much of the
debate is understandably about
individuals and families but
we don't want to see sort of mass
business closures as well so we do need
to focus on the energy costs that
they're facing too it's going to be
expensive though isn't it um list trust
has ruled out a windfall tax do you
think that was the right thing to do
well
we already have a windfall tax at the
moment so um it's already the case that
the
the big energy producers
are contributing to
solving this problem and and we have a
progressive tax system so higher earners
and companies will all be playing their
part in
in funding all of this
so i i don't think it was an
unreasonable decision for
for liz to say that she wasn't going to
introduce
a specific new windfall tax but
i i feel it's best to wait for the
detail in the package to see how it will
operate and how it will be funded in
detail yeah we are of course waiting
that aren't we and tomorrow's
announcement and but at the same time if
she's not going to go for her tax risers
then it looks likely it's going to be
funding by a pretty big increase in
borrowing i spoke to philip hammond the
former chancellor of the weekend
and he said that he's worried the
conservatives reputation for fiscal
responsibility and competent governments
at stake do you think that's right
this is this will have an impact on
borrowing in the public finances and so
there are risks i mean that that was
obviously the debate during the
leadership election but this is an
emergency i mean we we haven't seen sort
of an energy price shock on this scale
since the 1970s you know we we are
seeing vladimir putin using energy
prices as a weapon of war
and in times of emergency unfortunately
the public finances
are impacted then there's simply
no way to avoid that if we're going to
do what we have to do but i i'm i feel
confident that our new prime minister
will be looking very carefully at all
the numbers to try and minimize the
damage on the public finances and to
ensure that we can get them back on a
sound footing in the future i guess one
way to get it back onto the sound
footing would be three taxes though
something that she said that she doesn't
want to put up
well she's clearly ruled out um
that she's very clear about the tax
reductions that she want to make so i
i would suspect there's there's no sort
of flexibility on that but as i say yeah
i'm sure
she and her whole new team will be
looking carefully about how this is
funded uh you i'm just interested to
know as well you know
liz trust uh new prime minister you know
if this week of course you know she's
been pointing her new cabinet and she's
had her first promises questions today
what kind of prime minister do you think
she's going to be
i think she's going to be
determined resilient
and she's got real kind of grit and she
she is absolutely determined to deliver
so i
i very much believe and hope that she's
going to be able to do that she
faces these incredibly difficult
circumstances not just
energy price rises not just the war in
ukraine but
the aftershocks have covered on the nhs
as well
but
i think she
performed really strongly at prime
minister's questions and she's got a
long and impressive track record in
government of getting things done so
that's what i i think she's going to do
as prime minister you sat around the
cabinet table with her what what what's
she like
she is she's very engaging she's got a
good sense of humour and the years we
sat in cabinet together
for much of the time she was doing the
defra brief and i remember her staunchly
standing up for the
food and drink industry as one of our
most important sectors
so she's she's always been a very
impressive figure in government and in
parliament you of course didn't back her
in the leadership race you went for
rishi sunac um i have to say you know
looking at the cabinet appointments
it's pretty clear that she's rewarded
those people who were loyal to her like
admittedly there are some risky student
backers when you go further down the
rungs or the ministerial uh ladders when
it comes to the big
decision makers
she hasn't really made the most
inclusive cabinet has she
she's appointed some incredibly able
people to her cabinet and her government
you know we're we're a parliamentary
party with
with a great many very talented and
capable people and i think it's
understandable that um liz wants some of
her key allies in the big positions and
as you say you know she's appointed some
rishi backers and indeed she's appointed
people who directly stood against her as
candidates in the leadership elections
so in a way the people that she relied
on for their votes
i think so but i i think she's got she
has got a great team um and that that
includes
conserva mps from from all wings of the
party and i i sincerely wish them well
you know it is it just as we've been
discussing they face an incredibly
difficult task as difficult as any
government that's taken office
in decades